welcome to a bedroom tour Yes you heard
me correctly I actually have a lot of
tech in this room and some of it you
can't actually see I just recently got
an eight sleep pod so a huge thank you
to eight sleep for partnering with me on
a portion of this video I cannot wait to
show you guys this if you are new here
you might not know that I am obsessed
with sleep tracking and data and making
sure all of my health is tracked to a t
so having this addition into my life is
so incredible so right now you might not
even be able to tell that it's here it's
actually underneath all of my sheets
here so this is the eight sleep pod a
temperature controlled mattress topper
what's unique about it is it connects to
this little Hub right here and by the
power and magic of water it has these
tubes here that connect to the active
grid and that allows you to quickly heat
and cool each side of the bed this has a
lot of unique sleep tracking features as
you can see here in the app this is my
sleep Fitness score from last night
which is actually pretty good it tracks
things like your quality of sleep your
routine and your time slept you can see
your REM sleep your deep sleep and the
health metrics like your heart rate HRV
and breath rate it also gives you
routines you can see your sleep over
time and even sleep latency I can't wait
to sleep with this more so that I can
get some more information and have some
more data to share with you guys but so
far it has been so incredible and it
really does help me get a much better
night's sleep because my body is
actually being temperature controlled
I'll put a link in the description where
you can check out more information about
all of the cool things that apesleep has
to offer so now it's time for the rest
of the tour
um this is my sleeping side for whatever
reason I always like sleeping on the
left or whichever is like closest to the
door or the bathroom
um anyway this is my little night stand
here I like sleeping with my computer
nearby I mean I know you probably
shouldn't be sleeping close to Tech but
it just makes me feel at home I've also
got this nice little Nomad charger so
I've got dual Apple watch and wireless
charging and no this isn't an alcoholic
beverage it's actually just water one
thing that I hate is waking up in the
middle of the night just dying of thirst
so I always have a water on hand the
other thing that I like about this room
is the curtains are actually controlled
with this remote or so if I want to
close them
like I just push the button let's open
it back up so we have some light we also
have Maddie's little bed right here off
to the side this is where he sleeps when
he doesn't want to sleep in bed with me
and one thing that I did notice is
sometimes there are some sleep
disruptions with the eight sleep if you
do have a pet so that is definitely
something to note so when I know that I
really want to track my sleep I always
kind of push him off the bed to make
sure he sleeps in his own bed so it
doesn't disrupt my data overall this
entire room when I first moved in I
didn't have any curtains it was
completely white it was super boring and
I kind of like really dark tones
especially when I sleep it just feels so
comfy so what I was kind of going for
the look in this room was kind of some
gold and darker tones and of course the
most comfy soft blankets that you could
ever imagine and I think that we have
achieved that so I went with this dark
color and I absolutely love it and I
love these lamps too because they kind
of blend into the room but they also
have the gold accents that I was looking
for so moving on we have a TV here with
a nice little nightstand and to be
honest with you I don't really ever
watch this TV I think the only time I've
ever turned it on in the past several
years is when I was sick I actually I
don't even know where the remote is
right now so it's purely aesthetic I
feel like I should get a painting or
something here but I just always have
loved having a TV in the bedroom but I
don't really watch it another thing that
I love having in this room is this
little purifier and I like this because
it also has Heating and Cooling
capabilities so I don't have to
necessarily turn on the heat or the air
conditioning so not only will this give
me a little bit of heat or a little bit
of cool it will also purify the room of
all Air toxins so gotta love that so
over here I've got a nice little lamp
you might notice this from some of my
old YouTube videos this was my old
Studio lamp but it kind of fit the vibe
that I was going for like those warm
kind of wooden gold tones even though
this isn't gold it still kind of works
because the curtains are all white so it
kind of just sort of Blends in this is
also electronic so I can open this
remotely with that remote control so
over here we have the eight sleep Hub
and it is actually very quiet like I
don't even hear it at night and it's
pretty awesome because you can fill it
with water and it just silently Heats
and cools your bed also you might be
like what the heck is this you have a
router in your room
um kind of this is a helium Miner if you
know you know like it's just we'll just
leave it at that I've got another one of
the lamps over here just to kind of even
the place out so as you can tell this
room is very minimal because there's
something that I have found if my room
is cluttered that transcends into my
mind and my body in the form of
anxiousness and I cannot sleep like I
just know that there's mess so the rest
of my house can be a disaster but as
long as my bedroom is clean I just feel
Zen and I can rest easy there are so
many different tips that I've found for
helping yourself get better sleeps I
look forward to sharing those all with
you in my full eight sleep review stay
tuned for that don't forget to like
comment and subscribe and let me know
how many hours of sleep do you guys
average at night I'd love to hear it